To apply this to the segmentation
problem of vision,
we have to think a little bit about what
feature space we do this in, all right?
And it turns out for an awful lot
of what we do in clustering and
segmentation, and frankly just about
everything in computer vision,
the feature space you
use is what matters.
So here, I'm showing you that single
line, with the idea being that
we're just a grouping along a single,
intensity space.
So if I were to cluster,
using just this simple intensity space
what would it do to this panda picture,
and Professor Grauman in Texas,
she's got these, this thing for pandas.
Actually I think she got
these pictures somewhere.
Well, so let's see.
So here's our panda.
If I tell it that there's
going to be two centers, okay,
then I would get a division
that looks like this, right?
So you can see that basically, the
lighter pixels have been turned into one
region, and the darker pixels have been
turned into another region, all right?
Now, if I told it instead
there were three clusters,
you might look at something that
looks like this, all right?
And here you can see there's the bright,
the dark, and the grey, all right?
kind of like the good,
the bad and the ugly.
So what you're seeing here right away,
is one of the problems in
doing K means clustering.
We'll talk more about this, is that you
have to tell it how many clusters there
are, and there are methods for then
trying to figure that out beyond that,
but fundamental to K means is you
already know the number of clusters.
When you do this type of clustering,
you can think of this as quantizing
the feature space, right?
So those of you familiar
with vector quantization,
if you do it in multi-dimensional space,
the idea is you essentially carve
a continuous space up
into a set of buckets.
So this segment, this clustering is
a quantization of our feature space.